i'm sure you've all heard of vladimir
putin he's been the star of russia for
the past 22 years and it doesn't look
like he's going anywhere anytime soon
after all his approval ratings are over
80 percent
now of course i know a lot of you guys
don't believe these numbers but these
numbers are still very telling while
these numbers may not be indicative of
public support they are indicative of
his inner circle support one of the main
reasons that putin is able to get away
with starting a war and jeopardizing the
russian economy is because he has dozens
of rich oligarchs that back him up in
fact these oligarchs were the ones that
made putin precedent in the first place
and the most notable of these oligarchs
is ironically a man named vladimir putin
vladimir putin is the richest man in all
of russia coming in at 31 billion
dollars
aside from his extraordinary fortune
battalion was the former first deputy
prime minister of russia and this was
the position that he got for getting
president yadzin into power
so here's the story of vladimir putin
and how he made putin the tsar of russia
taking a look back platonin was born on
january 3rd 1961 in moscow this was
during the height of the cold war and
the infamous cuban missile crisis was
just around the corner so batanan's
entire childhood was filled with
communist propaganda and anti-us
sentiment this was especially the case
due to his father oleg oleg was a highly
respected soviet diplomat who traveled
internationally to meet with countries
like new zealand and australia meanwhile
batonnet's mother was a doctor who often
accompanied oleg on his business trips
this meant that batonin was often left
with his grandparents
despite this platonin has always
credited much of his wit and
intelligence to his parents
anyway platonin would end up following
in his father's footsteps and enroll in
the moscow state institute of
international relations this university
was especially designed to prepare
students to serve in the kgb and kremlin
sectors and that's exactly what platonin
would do after graduating in 1983. his
first job was at an arm of the ministry
of foreign trade called the fto soyuz
prom export he would spend his entire
20s here as he learned about the inner
workings of the ussr and built up a
professional network honestly i'm not
sure if he would have left the ministry
at all if the ussr was still strong you
see it the ussr would end up collapsing
the same year that baton and quit in
1991 so it looks like baton and left
sensing what was coming fortunately
though he was able to make a lot of
powerful connections during his time at
the ministry and he would leverage these
connections to set up a private
association called enteros on the
surface enteros was simply a trade
association that dealt with common
metals such as aluminum copper and lead
russia has a decent supply of all these
metals so it seemed like batoning was
looking to build up a classic raw
material business but this was not the
case interos was simply a front to run
his true money making scheme which was
the infamous financial scheme called
loan for shares
most of you are probably not familiar
with loans for shares because the scheme
is unique to russia and batonin himself
in fact platonin was the mastermind
behind the scheme it all started with
opening up two financial institutions
called the international company for
finance and onyx and bank baton and
founded these two institutions with a
business partner named mikhail procrove
who is also a deca billionaire today
anyway batonin would be made president
of the bank and the two would go on to
recruit depositors this was actually
super easy because they faced virtually
no competition you see private banking
was banned in the ussr and the only bank
in the entire country was the central
bank called gosbank batonin's onyx and
bank was one of the first banks to pop
up after the collapse of the ussr and
given all of batanan's connections from
the ministry onyxian was able to become
the largest private bank in russia in no
time and now that batonnet had money on
his side he started to put this money to
work at the time russia didn't have a
stock market or any prominent private
business basically everything was state
owned so if batonin wanted to gain
ownership in any of these businesses he
had to work with the government
fortunately for botanic this was
actually super easy because batonnet had
something that the government
desperately needed cash at the time the
president of russia was a man named
boris yeltsin who was up for re-election
very soon given that the country was
going through a massive liquidity crisis
his re-election prospects were iffy to
say the least so president yeltsin would
start looking for ways to raise cash to
save russia as well as his presidency
and this is where botana would step in
with this loans for shares program the
idea was actually super simple he was
basically just offering the government
margin loans batoning and his business
partners would bail out the government
and fund yeltsin's re-election campaign
if y'all sent put up 12 state-owned
energy and mining companies as
collateral yeltsin would of course take
the deal and batoning would help yeltsin
win re-election however this didn't
really help the russian government
change directions the government was
still burning loads of money and
batonnet's money just allowed for a few
more years of survival it wasn't long
until russia was facing a liquidity
crisis once again and this would
eventually climax in the 1998 russian
financial crisis during this crisis
russia would default on their debt which
meant that battalion and his friends
could keep the collateral for most
financial institutions this would be far
from ideal they'd rather just get their
money back than get stock or real estate
or whatever the collateral may be
but for battalion and his friends this
is exactly what they wanted
the loans that they gave russia were
extremely small relative to the
collateral that they had so they had hit
the jackpot they had basically just
margin called russia to become
multi-billionaires themselves
after such a public failure i don't
think you'd be surprised to hear that
yeltsin lost all public support there
was no way for him to win yet another
election so he would do the honorable
thing and step aside
i am leaving i have done everything i
can right before his term ended in 2000
the altoona would go ahead and resign
and tap on vladimir putin to become
acting president until the next election
in the meantime bhutan was having the
time of his life after yeltsin's initial
victory battalion was appointed as the
first deputy prime minister however
battalion didn't stick around for long
he would leave in march of 1997 as he
could sense what was coming and he
didn't want to be on that side of the
crisis instead he spent his time
building up companies that are valuable
and uploading ones that weren't for
example he was keen on protecting his 54
stake in nornico which was a nickel
mining and smelting company meanwhile he
offloaded positions in other companies
like spiazenbest
was a telecommunications giant in russia
but it seems that baton knew that it was
a garbage company on the inside so he
started looking for potential targets
that he could sell his position to and
he landed on george soros he convinced
soros to invest 980 million dollars into
the company in return for 25 stake soros
would eventually realize that this was
the worst investment of his life so far
batonin had left the old senate and
soros out to die but he wasn't so
careless with all his relationships one
relationship that he highly valued was a
friendship with putin it was clear to
batonin that putin was gonna be in power
for quite some time so he was in his
best interest to stay on putin's good
side and that's exactly what he's done
according to u.s treasury poon's inner
circle is made up of 210 individuals out
of which 96 are oligarchs and given that
bataanan is the richest of them all
there's no doubt that he has quite a bit
of influence on putin and now that
patanan had putin's ear he would return
to his treacherous behavior
one of the first people that platonin
would turn on is mikhail progrove if you
don't remember this was the guy that
helped baton and set up the onyx and
bank and eventually the loan for shares
program in 2007 batonnet announced that
he was splitting ways with the pro grove
and he would launch a bid to buy out his
stake in nornickel he offered just one
billion dollars for pro crow of steak
according to pro grove his 25 stake was
worth 15 billion dollars pro grove would
turn to putin for support and putin
would actually side with pro grove
probably because putin buys loyalty over
everything else and platonin was clearly
not loyal putin would go ahead and call
baton in it and chew him out saying
quote it's dishonest to cheat on
partners thanks to putin's support pro
grove would be able to sell a stake to
oleg derapaska instead who gave him a
much more reasonable 8 billion dollars
they escaped pro crow and out from this
fiasco but batonin was obviously not
happy he shifted his dispute over to
deraposca and this lasted all the way
till 2012. at this point a man named
roman abramovic would buy a 6.5 stake in
nor nickel and he would basically become
a peacemaker between these two this
stopped the fighting between platonin
and derpasca but now patonin has brought
the fight over to abramovic in february
of 2018 he offered to buy four percent
from abramovic clearly this guy does not
stop until he gets what he wants this is
not that big of a problem when he's
simply fighting other businessmen who
are probably just as ruthless but it
becomes quite an issue when his actions
affect the environment as there's no one
to protect the environment historically
nornico has been one of the largest
polluters of the russian arctic as of
2013 nornico was discharging 500 tons of
copper and nickel oxides as well as 2
million tons of sulfur dioxide every
year this pollution has reduced the life
expectancy of people living in the area
by 10 years relative to the rest of
russia putin has been asking platonin to
reduce his pollution for quite some time
but platonin has yet to take any
meaningful action if anything things
have only gotten worse
in fact in may of 2020 nor nickel had an
oil spill that flooded russian rivers
with 21 000 tons of diesel this was
russia's second largest oil spill of all
time and has resulted in a two billion
dollar fine for nor nickel hopefully a
financial punishment is enough to change
baton's ways but only time will tell
despite all the terrible deeds batoning
has been involved in things have been
going quite well for him in fact
madonna's ferment nor nicole is one of
the biggest russian firms that hasn't
been sanctioned by the western world at
large
only a few countries such as the uk and
canada have sanched off his company the
rest of the world hasn't really taken
any action against batonin due to how
important his company is to the global
metal industry this is why baton in it
is one of the only russian billionaires
who hasn't shed much of his wealth this
year he's basically at break even while
the rest of the russian billionaires are
down 5-10 billion since the beginning of
the year so clearly things have been
playing out pretty well for protonin and
looking forward it it doesn't seem like
his wealth or influence will be
disappearing anytime soon especially
given that he's not even hurting due to
the sanctions so all we can do is hope
that autonomous kills back his pollution
and uses his influence for good instead
of supporting unnecessary wars but
that's just what i think would you like
to see botana's demise comment that down
below
also drop a like if you're not a fan of
batoning and of course consider checking
out our discord community to suggest
your video ideas and consider subscribe
and see more questions logically
answered but until then i'm hari and
i'll see you guys on next one
you